- Do y'all wanna watch
me fail my driver's test?
Here we go.
(upbeat music)
- I am 27 years old, grew up in Brooklyn,
and I do not have my driver's license.
- I am 27 years old, I was
born in the state of Texas,
and I do not have a driver's license.
- I'm from India, and I
have never driven a car.
- I am 30 years old, I'm
from Texas originally,
where I have a, a permit.
(laughs)
- I'm 29 years old,
originally from the Bronx,
living in Harlem now, and I do
not have a driver's license.
(fast, upbeat music)
- You are making a left
turn from a two-way street
and into a one-way street.
When you have completed the
turn your car should be:
- From a two-way street
into a one-way street?
- I, what, I,
I need a picture.
- If you turn into a one-way street,
there isn't a left or
right lane, so I think
that eliminates the last two.
- This is a two-way street.
- Great, that's two lanes there.
- Making a left turn, maybe
I shouldn't get my license.
- I'm gonna say, in the
left lane of the street.
- When two vehicles enter an
intersection from different
highways at the same speed, which vehicle
must yield the right-of-way?
- Oh heck.
- Oh God, it's either to
your left or your right.
(laughs)
- I don't know if I've ever
been in a car that did that.
- You're not supposed
to signal somebody on,
like you're supposed to go.
Cause then if they get in an
accident, it's your fault.
- I think it's the vehicle
on your right, I'm guessing.
- I'm gonna say vehicle on the
left, because I have no idea,
and that's like the first option there.
- What does a slow moving
vehicle emblem look like:
They don't even show pictures,
they just have words.
- Eenie, meanie, miney, moe.
- I feel like I'm in like, minesweeper,
where every single square
could just be to my demise.
- I don't know, maybe it's
the triangular orange sign,
that's just a guess.
- I'm gonna go with,
triangular orange sign.
- Assuming that the street
is level, what should you do
after you have finished
parallel parking in a space
between two other cars?
- I just, like, think of parallel
parking, and I know, like,
this is wrong, just like
going in, but I think of like,
these big suburban malls,
and when the cars are like,
parked next to each other.
- I straight, oh gosh, you
turn the wheels in some way,
and I don't know which way.
(laughs)
- I told you parallel
parking is not my thing.
I don't love this.
- And, I do remember that if you park
on a downhill slope, parallel park,
you have to turn the wheels in.
- So, even though I didn't
pass the parallel parking part
of my road test, I know
this part to be true.
Straighten your wheels, and
leave the room between cars.
- On a road which has no sidewalks,
a pedestrian should walk on the:
- I wanna say, oncoming traffic.
- The side of the road
where the traffic is moving,
cause, that's also where cars should go.
- You don't, wait, do you
face oncoming traffic?
So you can see it?
Someone told me you should
face the oncoming traffic
so you can see a car about to hit you.
- I'd say, side of the road
facing oncoming traffic.
- I think, facing oncoming traffic.
You definitely don't want cars whizzing
from behind you, so
probably, would wanna see
what's going on in front of you.
- The driver's left arm and
hand are extended downward.
That's a chill driver.
This hand signal means
that the driver plans to:
- So, I've seen drivers
do this, and I didn't know
it was a thing, I just
thought they were like,
hanging out, being cool in their car.
- I'm gonna go with a turn left,
similar to how it is in bicycling.
- I think they're stopping.
I think that means stop.
(upbeat music)
- Oh wait, I passed.
- What?
I passed!
Oh my God!
- I passed!
- I have failed!
(laughs)
- I wouldn't use the word
excited, I'm rather relieved
(laughs)
that I passed.
- I think if you just like,
use your common sense,
and if you've been in a car,
like a few times in your life,
I think you're gonna be fine.
- I don't wanna make any
promises, but I think
after today, I'm gonna
go out there and at least
try to get a driver's license.
- I am bad at driving, and probably bad
at questions about driving.
So I will continue not driving.
- Ha-hah!
Catch me on your roads in 2018, baby.
Clark's getting his driver's license.
(upbeat music)